The next of the Beta Sprints to present
is one of two, that are based at Harvard
and affiliated with the Berkman Center,
one of the reasons we had outside reviewers was a
conflict of interest that might lead me to approve these
things of my colleagues, but I am delighted that these were chosen.
Jeffrey Snape and Carol Oehler
and her colleagues worked on a project which would be
very different slides into the world of what might be possible
and have very excited to see what they have to say.
The slides are coming up who did not have encouraged to
run a live demonstration but there is one of by the
poster session if you would like to play around with ExtraMUROS
and it has been working well today so we would be happy
if you have the opportunity to play around with it.
What we would like to do is introduce you to ExtraMUROS
which is a project whose aim is to shape the digital
public Library of America  into a user Center multimedia
library without walls built on public API.
And the aim of ExtraMUROS is to transform the way people discover, curate
and disseminate questions -- collections of books,
images, sounds, video, and other media.
ExtraMUROS provides discovery, territorial
and offering tools that allow users to effortlessly
create their own collections of multimedia projects.
And it is built using Zeega, an open source HTML platform that
we are glad to say was a recent winner of the Knight Foundation's news challenge.
Now the project is being led by MetaLab at Harvard
And it's being developed in conjunction with the Loeb Library
at the graduate school of design, the Harvard Library Lab and Zeega.org
Now there are five main components to ExtraMUROS
and the first is shared access.
ExtraMUROS interconnects online holdings
from libraries, heritage institutions, local historical associations
and archives across the country as well as repositories
like Internet Archive, Flickr, and YouTube.
And visual discovery is a second -
rather than relying on keyword searches,
ExtraMUROS allows users to explore collections and intuitive  and nonlinear ways,
offering icon-based searching, personalized sorting trays
and geographic visualizations of search results that are
zoomable. Duration. ExtraMUROS allows the general public,
students of all ages, students
and scholars to collaboratively curate,
scholarand share online exhibitions,
slideshows that combine text, individual images,
audio and video great .  Multi-channeling,
ExtraMUROS makes curated editions
and multimedia projects accessible on iPADS
and other mobile devices and online
and are trying to build a bridge between the local
and the national and the national and the local.
ExtraMUROS makes it possible  to feature local archives
and collections is a function of user location
and envisages building DPLA kiosks of  literal physical
bridges that will host local and national curatorial projects.
Let's show you a little bit of what we have built so far.
One interesting subject we focused upon was the history
of the American landscape this is a collection of
digitized magic lantern slides from the Library of Congress
and they're currently available on the Library of
Congress website, and digital form,
but they are pretty difficult to access, browse, and use,
so when using ExtraMUROS, can search within this collection,
we are typing in American landscape we can view it as
images  or categories or even make our own collections.
Here, we are seeing user added collections and astronomy,
starry night, fountain, Chicago world's fair. The
Now we are looking at just images in the catalog about
the Chicago world's fair. If we go to Flickr, we also find hundreds,
thousands more photos of the same exposition.
And this is one of the Smithsonian collection
and we allow users to add text
and media they would encounter
and we can add those to the ExtraMUROS database andd we
will type in where the Chicago fair was back in 1993.
And you get a lot of other extra metadata as well
and so we're adding it to our database
and if we go back to ExtraMUROS,
we can see the new media that we have just added aa
and we have made it a and the lab
and we had that to the database
and before we go back to ExtraMUROS vacancy at all
and it allows us to add and incorporate text , audio
and video across the web and so now, a
Are also enabling tools to allow the public to curate
author and share and Augmentin annotate books.
Here's an example of all we are going to be showing you
right now on the user edited version of Robert Riddell's 1984 book,
all the world is a fear that shows the potential of
integration of ExtraMUROS with a ShelfLife progress at
the Harvard library integration my integrated a new
project using the ExtraMUROS activator and research the database
and we drag individual pages of the book to the editing
trade to rebuild the book's opening chapter added to
click on preview, as we are seeing right now,
you will see what the published version will look like.
You can also examine associated books in this case,
they're looking at the ShelfLife stack of books related
to all the world is a fair  as a means of excavating
footnotes are locating related or similar volumes. Now,
let's go back to her outfit to the edition
and see what this looks like after a little bit of editorial work.
Here we have highlighted the footnoted citation.
Click and we see the quotation from the original source,
and we see the source of the book itself, Lucy Osgood.
Taking advantage of the storytelling capabilities,
we decide to develop a separate path relating to the
history of this specific book so that in a couple of clicks,
we can show that Lucy Osgood donated $12,000 with the books to Harvard University
and her pituitary shoes quoted as saying there is a
greater need of intelligent readers, then writers.
And she was eminently one of them, as it turns out.
Let's go back for a second to Riddell's book from you come across a Japanese pavilion
and a subsequent illustration of versions of illustration
from Riddell's book and then we see,
we have inserted a lantern slide of the Japanese pavilion
from the Library of Congress and we have overlaid,
the slide dissimulation video of the world fare from UCLA.
ExtraMUROS never copies of source files for each piece of
media has automatic TrackBack to its original location
and if you open a tab,
you can go back into these locations.
I saw that we need to stop,
we have quite a bit more than we are going to show you
but I think we will skip it.
Do you want to do another beat or two
and we can take one question for you guys but that is okay.
Here, this is a showing,
another way of visualizing data so you can see it on a
map and you can search by location,
you can see it by what kinds of media are available in
that location. And right now,
we decided to pull out images
and audio of amusement parks. Here,
we find a collection from the Revere Beach historical
Society. For those of you that don't know,
just like the Coney Island of Boston.
We can just review audio files. Here,
we are just seeing the ideal files,
oral histories from the Beach historical society
and this last bit, you have made it so you can seamlessly
incorporate Google Maps Street view
and we are having talk about someone talking about what
used to be there while you are viewing current images
and here is an example out of her mouth have audio.
It is no longer visible, of course. In conclusion,
what the project seeks to do is transform the public
Library of America into a participatory public space for
users don't just search and retrieve records, but rather,
engage in individual and collective acts of making and doing
and our vision is of a world in which libraries encourage
all citizens to treat the cultural patrimony of humanity
as if it were their own, to learn from it, to make things with it,
to share these things than engage in a lifelong
societywide process of learning. Thank you great
Pretty extraordinary and exciting, you guys.
I'm going to suggest one question,
curtly shy hugely encouraging to go to , Web.
It's nice to have it explained.
It -- it's amazing to experience this.
One person who would want to lob a question of these guys?
Yes, please.
Hello? How would you handle a service,
any of the services that you are sort of linked to?
May be becoming available
or something like that when you are very respectfully,
don't copy any of the source ? It is for archives and all that,
I guess it's not that much of a challenge for someone
like you to, to submit for some weird reason.
That's definitely a question.
We've been building into see -- whoa. Lots of Mike phone.
We've been building in chat mechanisms to see if the
source of the file changes.
And then to notify users to see if that file has changed within their project.
The realities that we have this kind of supposition that somehow digital information is everlasting.
Where as we think that paper is just sort of the more
like thing that could go and die at some point.
Of course till information will die as well
and this project doesn't suppose total preservation.
I think it suggests that we need to think creatively
about what forms and where we can build those
and we're different sources and sites,
what would it mean to archived these is?
You don't archive all of Flickr, different licensing
and forms of items that could contribute have a project,
it that might be one week comes into the system but then
it's archive life might be one that's independent of Flickr itself.
[Applause]